[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
kss kss kss kss kss ne te découvrir mais
je trop content tu le faire ça fait
tellement vite paraître ce sujet un
sujet qui me passionne toute une salle
comme ça génial génial ça c'était il ya
deux mois à vos filles tu crois vraiment
que tu vas parler de la gestion des
émotions à toute la salle pendant 10
minutes et que ça va les intéresser la
gestion des émotions c'est hyper
galvaudé tout le monde en parle mais
comment tu vas faire ok tu as l'habitude
de faire les présentations etc
mais ce suivi par an ça c'était cette
semaine
il ya deux jours elle a maintenant je
suis devant vous forcément un peu peur
un petit peu d'excitation beaucoup tu
peu de réconfort voyez je me tiens les
mains - bien que s'ils tiennent
ça vous arrive ça au bas pourtant c'est
quelque chose que vous avez voulu vous
êtes préparé vous avez dit oui je veux
le faire vous avez levé le doigt appuyé
pourtant il ya des gens comme ça qui
prennent de l'énergie la gestion des
émotions pour moi ça a longtemps été
compliqué ça m'a plutôt apporter des
ennuis jusqu'au jour
où j'ai accepté de faire différemment
et puis j'ai découvert comment les gérer
et c'est cette découverte que je
voudrais partager avec vous aujourd'hui
vendredi soir
la semaine est finie a été compliqué
problème au boulot les enfants malades
la voiture est tombée en panne ça se
trouve mami a eu un peu de neige voilà
dernière ligne droite
apéro dîner bon on a préparé un bon
petit plat on ya mis toute notre énergie
enfin ce qui nous en restait et on est
prêt à savourer on est assis à la table
là mais c'est pas mal chéri mais manque
pas un petit quelque chose par rapport à
la dernière fois on m'attend si tu veux
tu as qu'à faire un tas cathy coller à
la cuisine enfin moi j'ai passé toute la
semaine là je fais un bon petit plat est
vraiment quelque chose
ah non mais ça va ça va enfin c'est
super hein pourquoi tu dis ça maintenant
que m'enfin c'est toi que jamais content
en vain voilà ça vous parle c'est la
vraie vie en fait ça c'est quand les
émotions prennent le dessus
c'est quand en fait on les gère pas du
tout et qu'on est le jouet de nos
émotions c'est les émotions qui nous
vole notre territoire savez quand on a
les jambes qui bouge un peu
on a l'estomac noué n'a la gorge serrée
le souffle un peu court
ben en fait on est sous le coup de
l'émotion
on gère bien de tous
et si pourtant l'émotion est un messager
et venez nous dire quelque chose et
qu'il fallait s'en servir pour se dire
'ok bientôt après tu es un truc qui va
se passer ou la houle ou là tenez par
exemple vous là là là vous avez regardé
des têtes vous savez parfois le speaker
peut s'approcher du public voire même
interagir avec le public voire même
invité le public à venir sur scène pour
partager avec moi à là je sens le
monsieur qui pose le téléphone d qui me
revient donc à une surprise
il ya eu excitation peur à tout d'un
coup et puis cette personne qui fait ça
comme ça ou l'autre qui est prête et je
sens dans les yeux le moi moi moi moi
qui ai même presque prêt à répondre à la
question que j'ai pas encore posé et
bien voilà d'émotion vient nous dire
tenez vous prêts mettez-vous en action
il va se passer quelque chose et vous
êtes prêt à réagir dans les deux cas
donc on est ok on a compris que
l'émotion ça serve à quelque chose ça
servait à nous dire d'accord il va se
passer quelque chose il faut que je sois
prêt à réagir d'ailleurs c'est le mot
émotion le sens étymologique émotions
deux motions mouvement donc ces
mouvements à l'extérieur donc c'est pour
ça que ça brille comme ça donc on est
prêt donc maintenant on sait qu'on va
réagir mais comment on va réagir à ce
qu'on est capable de réagir ou est ce
qu'on est capable de réagir
donc on est en réunion une réunion hyper
importante de l'enjeu des gens
importants n'est prêt et puis là tout
d'un coup arrive la question la question
à laquelle on n'a pas la réponse vous
surprise déstabilisation
peur colère pourquoi ils me posent cette
question
hélas a réagi non mais qu'est ce que
c'est que cette question t'as pas lu le
président sait marquer page 3 ça n'a
rien à voir avec ce qu'on est en train
de discuter aujourd'hui alors s'il te
plaît tu reviendras tu prépares tu es
réunion tu vas arrêter de faire perdre
de temps là c'est sortir donc là on a
fait un peu le bulldozer on a tout mis
est-ce qu'on était ajustée est ce qu'on
laisse une chance à la personne en face
ou alors il ya une deuxième manière
qu'on peut voir que vous êtes peut-être
vécu un texte certains d'entre vous dans
la salle qui réagissent comme ça c'est
on se concentre très fort sur le carreau
entre la 21e et la vingt deuxième lignes
de la feuille le regarde très fort et
avec le stylo on repasse au tour et en
attend que ça passe comme ça on se dit
gère en fait c'est monté mâles house et
monte monte monte monte et puis ça
refait mal quand ça redescend redescend
redescend à dessein et puis parfois en
plus ça reste donc ça continue à faire
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il ya une
troisième manière de pouvoir réagir et
c'est ce dont je vous ai parlé au début
de ce dead qui est la découverte que
j'ai fait qui est ni le rouleau
compresseur ni le jeu garde tout pour
moi je mets le couvercle ni je suis noyé
dans mes émotions parce que je sais plus
comment faire
ni le je suis coupé presque je ne
ressens plus rien qui est tout bêtement
nommé l'émotion c'est tout simple
parfois tu as fait la différence
donc on est en colère non colère ce
qu'il ya un truc qui vraiment va pas
écoute ce que tu me dis ça met hors de
moi je suis super en colère c'est une
discussion qui est hyper importante mais
je suis tellement en colère que là je
risquerais des choses de dire des choses
que j'ai pas du tout envie de dire puis
après ça va aller très loin donc tu
donnes cinq minutes je sors et ensuite
on revient et on continuer la discussion
mais là je peux pas eh bien parfois
juste cette petite réaction d'arriver à
dans ce petit interstice entre le moment
où on nomme l'émotion le moment aurait
agi injecté ce tout petit moment où on
prend du recul
en nommant l'émotion ça change tout
comme une fois on aurait voulu dire d'un
mois ces cinq minutes
et peut-être que la discussion aurait
été différente si qu'on est pressé juste
nommé l'émotion pour arriver à prêts à
la mettre à distance et à faire
différemment
d'ailleurs quand je suis rentré sur
scène et que je vous ai décrit ce que je
ressentais c'est ce que j'ai fait c'est
ce que j'ai fait en vous disant ce que
je ressentais que j'avais besoin d'un
petit peu de réconfort et que j'aurais
aimé que donc finalement en faisant ça
on reste authentique avec ses valeurs on
ne se trahit pas parce que moi si je
vous dis que depuis toujours on cherche
à gérer nos émotions à les cacher vous
n'allez pas me croire mais bien compris
que moi je faisais plutôt partie de la
catégorie de ceux qui envoient le
bulldozer pour autant quand on se dit
que on arrive à canaliser cette énergie
qu'on arrive à utiliser la force de ce
qu'on a ressenti pour délivrer le bon
message pour être juste à tout moment
avec les gens qu'on aime qui sont
importants pour nous que le jour où j'ai
réalisé que je pouvais le faire que
j'arrivais à pas être obligé de durcir
pour dire des choses importantes ou pas
obligé de cacher les sentiments et la
bienveillance où la tendresse que
j'avais pour les gens qui étaient en
face de moi le jour où j'ai réussi à le
faire et bien j'ai découvert une
nouvelle liberté
et puis j'ai remarqué que ça contribue à
l'authenticité parce qu'on dise coursan
est tout le monde ressent ça on n'est
pas obligé de le cacher on s'en sert
juste pour donner du poids à ce qu'on
dit accompagné donc ça contribue aussi à
mettre de l'authenticité
alors arriver à les gérer et non plus à
les cacher arrivé à utiliser cette
formidable énergie que ça nous procure
pour délivrer le bon message
en tout moment mais moi ça a changé ma
manière de vivre ça a été ma liberté et
ça a été la reconquête de mon territoire
intérieur
merci
[Applaudissements]